bonjour à tous connaissez-vous le projet
mardi pan un projet dont on a déjà parlé
un projet d'apple un projet en tout cas
qui pourrait arriver d'ici quelques
temps chez apple
l'idée c'est d'unifier les applications
ios aux applications mac os alors je
vous expliquez vous allez voir c'est pas
si compliqué que ça en a l'air
on y va
[Musique]
sans projet qui est évoqué par
marguerite man qui est journaliste à
bloomberg qui a déjà parlé du projet
mardi en fin 2010 est l'idée c'est pour
les développeurs d'avoir un même
écosystème pour développer aujourd'hui
vous avez des dispositifs que sont quand
même relativement différent entre d'un
côté mac os d'un côté à ios pour ipad
est aussi pour iphone les applications
pour ipad et pour iphone sont pas les
mêmes les applications pour mac os sont
vraiment pas du tout les mêmes là l'idée
c'est qu'un seul et même développeur
pour développer une application qui peut
être utilisé d'un côté comme de l'autre
c'est quelque chose d'assez intéressant
et compenser qui aurait pu arriver cette
année au débat nous aveugle ou dc a
priori ce ne serait pas le cas en tout
cas c'est ce que dit john gruber qui est
un blogueur qui est plutôt très très
bien informé il a des contacts plutôt
privilégié du côté de chez apple et
effectivement il dit que même ce nom de
code marzy pont n'était pas du tout
connue par les équipes d'apple
effectivement ce projet existerait le
nom de code serait différent et le
connaître et il n'aurait pas voulu
communiquer dessus mais effectivement
quelque chose qui pourrait arriver
pas cette année mais probablement en
l'idée en tout cas est vraiment
intéressante alors tim cook a dit
qu'effectivement cette question qu'on
retrouve sur un os n'ont pas vocation à
y de la même manière ait fait de la même
manière sur macos effectivement ça reste
quand même deux produits vraiment
distingue pas utilisé de la même manière
mais l'idée pour le développeur de
pouvoir travailler sur un seul et même
écosystème pour développer et qu'on
puisse le retrouver un peu partout ça
paraît assez logique alors effectivement
j'en parle de façon assez vulgariser
parce que je ne suis pas développeur
j'ai pas mg par les termes exacts mais
on comprend que du point de vue du
consommateur ce qui est vraiment très
intéressant c'est de se dire que un
produit qui va être sur son ipad on va
pouvoir retrouver sur son iphone de la
même manière pour un développeur sans
qu'ils aient besoin d'aller retravaillé
redévelopper parce que c'est quand même
frustrant aujourd'hui c'est se dire
qu'on a des applications sur son iphone
qu'on peut pas avoir sur son ipad est
alors n'en parlons même pas du côté de
mac os même si effectivement on va pas
les utiliser de la même manière d'un
côté comme de l'autre on devrait pouvoir
quand même les retrouver et du côté
consommateurs ça pourrait être plutôt
cool
en fait ça pour être un rapprochement de
langage du point de vue des développeurs
il travaillerait sur un socle commun au
lieutenant des univers qui sont vraiment
différents je pense que ça ça résume
assez bien ça d'ailleurs si vous êtes
vous développeurs dites moi si je me
trompe pas trop si j'explique plutôt
bien
idée du truc est ce que c'est ça parce
que c'est un socle commun alors que
c'est vraiment un langage qui est
complètement différent et qu'il sera
pour le coup complètement différent en
tout cas c'est très intéressant et ça
c'est qu'on voit qui pourrait y avoir de
nouveaux produits qui arriverait dans un
futur plus ou moins proche plus ou moins
lointain pour apple et d'avoir quelque
chose d'unifier on part effectivement de
smartphones pliable on parle d' ipad
pliable on peut imaginer que l'iphone et
l'ipad devienne un seul et même produit
on peut imaginer aussi qu'un ipad
devienne un petit ordinateur avec un
clavier un peu comme ipad pro mais en
beaucoup plus puissant on peut imaginer
qu'ils aient une vraie compatibilité des
produits qui puissent vraiment
communiquer plus facilement entre des
applications qu'on pourrait commencer à
travailler sur un ipad on pourrait finir
sur un macbook sans forcément que
l'application soit différente moi je
dois vraiment du point de vue
consommateur avoir une vraie
productivité hyper simplifiée ça
pourrait être super cool et avec un
partage des données sur le cloud c'est
déjà des choses qui existent aujourd'hui
on le voit notamment avec des logiciels
comme des logiciels de traitement de
texte avec des tableurs et des choses
comme ça mais si toutes les applications
signifié on pourrait aller encore plus
loin et pour le coup ça pourrait être
super intéressante
dites moi ce que vous en pensez ce que
vous trouvez que le concept écouler ce
que ça pourrait vous tente effectivement
d'avoir des applications complètement
unifiée pour mac pour ios marquer ma
tout son commentaire comme d'hab vous
invite à rester connectés à vous abonner
parce que on va en pareil toujours plus
ça arrivera dans les temps à venir on en
reparlera plus tard dès qu'ils auront
encore plus d'infos dessus plus d'infos
pertinente
restez donc connectés d'ici là soyez ça
je vous dis à très bientôt
il est à l'essai des jolies pousse à
vous abonner et puis surtout vous
embrasse à bientôt
[Musique]